Scotch Mirren's the hypnotist and Sal is
under his voodoo charm
all right sale close your eyes exhale
you're sitting there relax going deeper
and deeper and deeper and in a moment
I'm gonna count forwards from one two
three and when I reach the count of
three you're gonna open your eyes and
your penis will be completely and
totally gone penis involves will just be
gone there'll be nothing there there's
no place for you to find it you won't
know where it is like someone had
actually stolen it 1 2 3 open your eyes
ok so I think so dad what the [ __ ] did
you do what do you mean what's going on
Sally my [ __ ] is God my [ __ ] is gone
what do you mean
[Music]
close your eyes close your eyes close
your eyes I think come on is he for real
now I'm gonna count to three and your
[ __ ] will be back 100 I had a whole
thing I was up blame it on Robin and I
get mad at Robert Kyle your [ __ ] is back
holy mackerel are you okay alright so
I'm not okay okay I'll close your eyes
close your eyes close your eyes relax
how'd you do that
it's okay oh she's crying Oh close your
eyes
that's not nice problem I didn't do
anything she didn't do it
close your eyes get rid of that memory
everything's the way it was before
you're fine
one two three open your eyes Wow well he
really is hypnotizable isn't he now what
happened you look down and it was like
really weird there was nothing there
dude wow it was bad I wish this upon
anybody it was insane I was really
scared it looked like okay like a Ken
Lee up see it yeah Wow exactly what I
saw yeah way to go Scott
dude I never said it was like a horror
movie with YouTube that was scary
first I thought you were kidding
and then I really don't one could scream
like that for that long
Oh God you okay yeah I'm fine I'm fine
I'm fine
all right never better